this week we've got gay puppets gay it's
CBD soda and kidney stones Oh what the
deal but start with the CBD soda then
yeah yeah no we've never started with
number two article also I want to know
about these gay puppets I want to know
what about these kidney stones a plot
twist all three of these are just one
article
okay puppets with kidney stones drinking
that CBD to make that kidneys don't go
away peacefully all right so for the
first story
you guys remember Bert and Ernie right
oh yeah the gays puppets yes they're bad
buddy
they're [ __ ] gay no no but that was
what people were saying because they're
always like sleeping together friend I
thought they were best friends I think
there's a kid I never even I didn't even
know gay existed and even when I used to
use the term gay freely
I never even called him gay you know
what you used to like your friend you
wanna go watch the movie like now I'm
busy are you so gay dude yeah so back in
those days when I just say gay like the
dog was gay the [ __ ] donut shops yeah
everything was gay still never called
then gay but yeah that's true it's like
you never looked at him and said they're
so gay if you're anything Big Bird's gay
yeah Big Bird big bird was super
flamboyant no big birds are comfortable
with his sexuality you think so big
birds more like Metro hmm yeah I agree
it yes oh this former Sesame Street
writer named Marc Saltzman he confirmed
that Bert and Ernie were gay how does he
know you asked them you could know the
writer he he joined Sesame Street in
1984 and he says that he wrote the pair
as a loving couple because he found
himself to be like so him and his
partner who the film editor
his name is Arnold so you come Arnie so
he's like yeah I felt like their
relationship was really similar with
mine and our needs relationship so I
would write them as a loving couple it
was like low-key do though like it
wasn't blatantly or maybe we just didn't
process it at the time but they wouldn't
kiss goodnight or anything no yeah but
[ __ ] okay so they're not like shirtless
with a [ __ ] cigarette like after sex
in bed they're just like I guess I make
sense that's a sex thing like in the 80s
that's when like isn't that one like the
YMCA's and like a lot of like the New
York club scene was also 70 something I
think yeah a lot of the New York club
scene was really getting that like in
the 80s so people were like comfortable
so I guess I'm not surprised that they
were like hey let's write a character
like I don't think people were
comfortable in the 80s or the 90s or the
early 2000s I thought they were brothers
or something and being Katyn being
insult like being being being called gay
or like no wonder everyone was terrified
yeah yeah dude I remember dudes would
get beat up for being feminine yeah in
high school like a guy would wear a
[ __ ] pink shoelaces or something
he'll get beat up so I feel like that
was kind of dangerous for them to do
that right it wasn't accepted yeah but
the producers of Sesame Street they came
out and they were like no no no no no
brain Ernie are not gay they're knocking
wait so the writer of Boerne says that
they are yeah but he wrote them as a
loving couple but the producers and also
Frank Oz who created the Burt character
he tweeted out and said that he and the
Muppets creator Jim Henson that they
never created them to be gay what about
the voice actors what are they say yeah
Ernie they don't sound gay at all well
they like holding hands in the vocal
booth while they're saying and doing all
the voice-over stuff or no cuz that's
the real question but then that would
make the voice people gay not the
character but if they're doing that to
channel like you know like you know like
when Vin Diesel was playing group he
pretended he was a platform
eight months fire I thought they were
dumb brothers I thought they were dumb
brothers yeah I thought they were dumb
goofy brothers yeah oh yeah so Sesame
Workshop they tweeted out saying that so
the characters they have human traits
but that they are just puppets and they
don't have a sexual orientation but then
when people are asking well then how can
some of the Muppets have significant
others like Miss Piggy and Kermit yeah
there were days well I was always like
why does Kermit even like her she's so
fast those were two separate things I
thought that piggy was really into
Kermit and he wasn't into her oh you're
right Muppets is some sesame sure you're
right we're getting confused yeah I'm
like those are separate and I always
thought the Muppets were a little bit
more human-like because they were on
relationships then Sesame Street well
what's the difference do not the same
thing both created by saying creator we
Kermit the frog's not on Sesame Street
Kermit the frog's not gay he's nosy
though cuz he's all the big Jim Henson
made both we come at the frogs on one
says how strict no he's not no I think
okay oh it's Elmo Gomez snuffleupagus
yeah Jim Henson bit bone and wait Kermit
Kermit's not obsessive no no no what
what did i watch that he was on there
he's not on there Elmo's on Sesame
Street right now what is Elmo sexual
orientation he's a monster they don't
have sexual orientation really he's like
a little kid
Elmo is a child with ADHD oh he's a baby
hmm and then Cookie Monster is a guy
with eating disorder no he's an addict
kooky monster is a crack addict yeah
he's a cookie the count is a Romanian
pimp
Oscar is just a Mexican guy gonna grab
no he's not
did they come out with some Spanish
characters after - they had a Spanish
Sesame Street Oh was it the same
character hold on
I'm so [ __ ] confused alright let's
clear it up
Kermit and Miss Piggy the puppets never
was on Sesame so no maybe they
- cameoed but they're not cast or they
they came on as puppets to do some [ __ ]
they never had their own thing on they
might have made a special appearance
what does the Imman Muppets for I'm mind
blown dude I don't know it's clearly a
variant of puppets yeah so Jim Henson
created Sesame Street and Muppets
Muppets and that's why right now when I
was saying it because the Bert character
creator said that he and Muppets creator
Jim Henson never created them to be gay
and then we started talking about so
they're not gay because the creator says
they're not good yeah but the other guy
who was the writer he said I wrote them
as being a loving couple and then
there's also a creator so how do we know
that's right or just also creator
invented the characters but the writer
made gay scenes for them that's what's
going on you took over maybe yeah maybe
he like he made gay scenes so they're
loving is that why they never wear pants
he's like a one of those we do wear
pants Bernardo wear pants just wear
shirts no they were pence let me see
our memory you know Google if they were
panel
eyes are clarified you think Jim Henson
didn't create Sesame Street she joined
the team to help create the characters
of the puppet anyway moving on to the
next story
so coca-cola announced that they are
interested in creating CBD like drinks
and foods with CBD I'm so surprised and
it's so crazy how strong and how hard
people are going with the CBD stuff cuz
there's not enough research to back a
lot of the claims that these companies I
feel like it doesn't really a link to
CBD water no I'm I've never so say it's
crazy like trend that I just don't want
to be a part of the CBD
if there's not researchers not much
testing no but the couple things I've
tried like creams it's [ __ ] good so I
have a collapsed arch on my left foot
and I put on CB and my right foot is
completely okay
I put the CBD cream on my left foot and
it got so relaxed and numb that I felt
like my right foot was
injured on my right foot is just
thankful it's strong I never tried it is
it good yeah right when I sprained my
ankle David gave me some of his and it
immediately like numbed it I mean not
wait cause it's still hurt but it helped
it a lot is the main ingredient CBD or
is there like bit like but was it pencil
no no it's mainly CBD so a lot of people
with a groin injuries actually like it
because by C hot it burns your nuts so
you can't really apply I see hot and
groin injuries but CBD because it's not
meant to your eye so you can put on your
o CVD is the agent in weed that relax
relax not
yeah relaxes your muscles and it's not I
like that THC though psychedelic it's
the hi it's like every why slow are you
gotta take away all the good [ __ ] mmm
that's like here's a cookie without the
sugar this is a medicinal part of it
that's the part that coke wants to be a
part of not the THC stuff Wow you drink
the soda and then your intestines go
numb
is that what's a new part oh you can't
feel it
no because they already have CBD infused
give me a THC coca-cola like mainstream
drinks no no I'm a stream but no I'm
saying like kind of crazy its lucrative
right now I think the whole marijuana
industry is so lucrative yeah what is it
what if someone gave you a [ __ ]
Slurpee but it tastes like vinegar water
what the it's the same thing yeah or
like they took away all the sweetness to
it and it is just it's just ice I think
that's what CBD is well people like CV
because like the average working person
like they don't want to be high but they
have so much pain and they don't want to
take a pill people like CV because it
comes from a plant these so does cocaine
as strong as [ __ ] though people have
that hope [ __ ] I have cocaine heroin
comes from a plant - it comes with a
poppy pot anytime you [ __ ] process
something it's it's no longer a plant
that's true that's very true it's also a
smart move on their part because like if
people our age aren't really drinking
coke because we want healthy stuff you
know if you do have like a healthy
approach I feel like the whole water
line and yeah
that's true but I mean like for Coke
products itself it was popular in the
50s and 60s and now they have to do
stuff to get this new generation in so
even just by putting out CBD coke
they're like saying oh we're hip we're
cool so if people don't even drink that
but they're so like coke is [ __ ] with
it is that what the kids are they need
some THC coke and hydro no smoke
whatever do that they need my syrup
because I've been there selling alcohol
is it that be genius because that's what
they're saying that the THC drinks that
would be better for like beer makers oh
that's for the tainted distorted so like
see videos more for like the health like
being healthy route I don't know if
anything coca-cola can be healthy true
they need to do more research though the
CBD
it's like they just got ahold of this
chemical and then now they've already
expanded and it's already reached the
public without rigorous testing I'm more
inclined to use the cream than to ingest
that [ __ ] I agree you sure cuz I
can't put nothing in my body
you got inhale all right I know I know
but it's so concentrated how he ate
animal you eaten CBD before yeah but
that's I don't know what the point that
cuz of the THC remember that hmm he
wants to teach you all the reward if you
boil that [ __ ] and make like THC butter
and then you cook and bake with that
he's down that's very that's a natural
process like a lab and put its problem
isn't it aren't you process yeah but
it's not as scary because it's like I
get it boiling water put a butter in
that [ __ ] melted together it's
good to go it's minimally processed
first things like how they would
probably make it which is boil it like a
[ __ ] ton and then afterwards you
dehydrate the water so now you have a
very concentrated powder of CBD or THC
it's like way different or like so much
more potent so guys in a lab coat and
[ __ ] using a coli to [ __ ] infiltrated
with all kinds of eco I don't mean like
I don't know which is crazy because like
most people like go to weed for
medicinal purposes they want to
stay away from pharmaceutical drugs
right yeah but then Lau what's happening
to weed is people in lab coats are
taking weed and extracting and doing
pharmaceutical [ __ ] to it it's the same
thing yeah as soon as you throw a lab
coat into the mix I'm out okay people
say like all the weed is natural man the
weed today is not even the same amount
of potency that like our parents
generation weed was like gosh it's way
weaker oh it's we're saying no no today
is stronger oh yeah it's like super we
because what they'll do is they'll get
the most potent and then they'll just
keep cross-product pollinating saying
this doesn't exist naturally in nature
we isn't that still natural though
because it's just too natural things
just cross pollinating yeah but it's not
like naturally pollinated in nature
we're just growing it's like we [ __ ]
put it on our own steroids I mean that's
how our produce and everything is today
like yeah like a watermelon today is not
like what it was before we cross
pollinated the [ __ ] out of it but then
it's like the potency is insane that's
also Kali though like in Virginia we
still got that doodoo weed that headache
dude that's stress
yeah like Callie's just got some crazy
marijuana yeah that's why I don't smoke
that much anymore so they're saying now
that some types of rollercoasters can
help remove kidney stones
you get kidney stones buyer you might
have to I'll be dope imagine getting
like kidney stones and then your doctor
prescribes you the [ __ ] terminator
ride or some [ __ ] or specifically the
one that they're talking about here is
Big Thunder Mountain oh I like that one
Oh is my insurance gonna cover my Six
Flags pass now
Disneyland ooh that's even more
expensive which one's big thunder melt
away don't won the Western it looks like
it's going through a mining town oh my
grandma loves that one I love riding
that one at night yeah that one's scary
but I like it
that wasn't one of the easier ones which
ones are harder wooden ones are sterile
pretty easy because they're so die
rickety in I don't feel safe that's true
yeah is it the fear or the the g-force I
think space Malin is scary because it's
you can't see I love thanks mom
I love that yeah did you if you close
your eyes in line and you just walk all
the way through and you get your night
vision back and when you're going around
you could actually see like where the
lights and all the posts are cut oh you
turn that yeah on Space Mountain I want
to keep my hands up but then I go like
this I don't know if it's gonna want me
to I'm always scared yeah thank you that
but yeah so they're saying that Space
Mountain wouldn't work for this because
the reason why Big Thunder Mountain
works for this is because they shake the
passenger like side to side up and down
there's a lot of bees literally shaking
these dodo it's just like catches dance
to like Harlem shake the kidney stone I
bet you hula don't get it krumpers don't
get kidney stone okay you pop them out
twerkers don't get kidney stone it's a
lot of dance moves you can do to not get
kidneys what about that but that
exercise machine where you stand on in
just shakes oh yeah 1950s [ __ ]
weight-loss [ __ ] or whatever the Asian
vibrator machine yeah those work no no
what is it working so this research here
it has won this year's big Nobel Prize
which I think is how you pronounce it
what Instagram i g IG nobel prize this
is a parody of the Nobel Prize
that's awarded every year oh cool a
parody yeah it's done
so it's like a legitimate it's about to
be a legitimate medical practice like
could a doctor prescribe me that roller
coaster I don't know if you have a
friendly doctor's familiar
it was just some like residential thing
that they're like you can't prescribe it
to people cuz it's not like sign that
sounds pretty fun though if you're like
well I heard kidney stones you could get
rid of it and then someone just goes to
Disneyland every day and instead of
paying for like stupid expensive doctor
bills they just do that there's no
separation no no it's like a hundred
bucks a person's over a hundred like 120
now that means only two rides and
there's only one day right yeah when I
move to LA like somebody was like come
meet Disneyland pass I looked it up like
a season pass it's like $700 not like
they're raising it to 1100 this year you
used to be more affordable because
they're opening the Star Wars area and
all that [ __ ] there's a calendar though
that you can kind of check when it's the
best time to go where there's not a lot
of people so there's like a Disneyland
calendar check it out I heard it was
Sunday nights cuz all the kids are in
school all the parents took him back and
he nobody there it was just like dead
I wanna go though cost too much money
I'll go
[Music]